[Musique]
où
je m'appelle les avis l'armée je
travaille comme pâtissière au restaurant
la maison d'à côté
à mon niveau j'ai toujours eu envie de
faire ce métier parce que mon papa
toujours eu un restaurant alors je fais
ça depuis depuis que j'ai 6 ans et ça a
toujours été une passion et notamment
pour le sucre et j'ai toujours voulu
être pâtissière
[Musique]
à mon plus beau souvenir lié à mon
métier bah ya un peu plus d'un an
maintenant j'ai fait objectif top chef
et la satisfaction quand monsieur
philippe etchebest nous a dit que
j'étais sélectionné pour la première
épreuve avec quatre étoiles sur 5 ça a
été mon plus beau souvenir avec les
petites larmes de mon papa et c'était
vraiment une satisfaction personnelle
est vraiment le résultat de mon travail
acharné donc pour réaliser la recette du
désir nous allons avoir besoin de beurre
de fait deux jaunes avec du sucre de la
notamment utilisent la la course sous
toutes ses formes sous forme d'une pure
et d'un jus et d' une brunoise confites
ainsi que un voile confie à l'huile
alors pour commencer on va préparer la
recette du crime tout rejet on va
d'abord faire chauffer notre jus de
courges
on va vraiment versé tout sur les jaunes
et le sucre
[Musique]
ici nous dresse des murs
skype
[Musique]
maintenant on va passer à dressage
donc on a notre biscuits ici par de sion
à mettre notre brunoise qu'on a confi
dans un sirop une fois notre crime eut
refroidi nous l'avons relie ces eaux
froides pour vraiment avoir quelque
chose de crémeux et de l'iss et pour
compléter le dessert nous avons un voile
un voile de course que nous avons confié
dans l'ue de l'huile de pépins de courge
[Musique]
pour finir on va vraiment avoir ce jus
de courge assaisonnée au vinaigre de
fleur d'acacia pour vraiment donner
cette petite touche d'acidité les bonne
dégustation
[Musique]